hello everyone and welcome to start with
white book club episode number four so I
wrote start with why I start with why
came out ten years ago and we're gonna
come out with a ten year anniversary
edition and so I have to reread it and
edit it to bring it up to date and make
all those changes so I figured why
should I read it by myself you would be
so nice to read it with other people
and that's how we had the idea for book
club in these Korona times we thought it
would be nice for people to do something
together to start a book club to read
books together discuss the books and
then we would all get together to answer
questions and hang out and talk about
start with y which is really fun so
thank you everyone who has joined us I
want to do a couple little shout outs
where the names of those gonna do some
shout outs from all the book clubs
around the world we've got clubbed
lectura de los dragon s welcome the JCI
it's Greenwich Book Club in London
welcome thank you for joining i we have
the virginia department of
transportation the road ahead book club
welcome welcome
rush no more book club I think you guys
and then that the bubble readership Club
in Oregon and my favorite the Dakota
potato peel pie and literary society are
back joining us again and I know this
folks from Egypt and Belgium and Denmark
and London and France and Turkey and
Poland and Toronto and Switzerland and
Ireland and Durham North Carolina and
Cape Town it's amazing it's wonderful
it's a global event it's so much fun to
see you all okay thanks for sending all
of your questions last time I talked
about what did I talk about last time we
talked about when we got into the thick
of the Golden Circle this time section
four was really about the movement
itself how to build the movement how to
turn the Y into a megaphone how it all
works together and one of the things I
wanted to share with you is this idea
the how type and the why type these
personalities now no one is purely one
or the other there
archetypes I have a friend named ash
Jamison and when she first became
familiar with my work and read this
chapter about why types and height how
types she decided that she hated me
because why types the the visionary idea
folks are the people we usually see
interviewed they're the ones who get all
the credit and so she felt very mad at
me because she didn't want to be a how
type she wanted to be a why type she
wanted to be a Big Idea person and it it
it took her about it a bunch of months
where she started to recognize that she
works with those big idea people and she
recognized that though they have big
ideas and though they have vision of the
future
they're completely useless without her
and what she realized was that as a how
type in a very high-functioning how type
I might add
- realized that she had even more value
than she was giving herself credit for
unfortunately our society tends to
lionize why types but it's completely
ridiculous how types are the more
functional personalities in our society
and they get things done and how types
can work at much bigger scale
world-changing stuff if they find a
vision that they align to and we gave
some of the examples Roy Disney had his
brother Walt Disney Ralph Abernathy
really was the one who was spearheading
organizing all of the pieces behind the
scenes for Martin Luther King Martin
Luther King was the Y type of the
visionary but Ralph Abernathy was the
one telling people get on the bus and so
you know it's like you have curly hair
you want straight hair you want you have
straight hair you want curly hair we all
wished I wish I was more functional like
getting things done and being more
system oriented but you know as long as
I surround myself with people who are
really good at it then we can get things
done together so all you Y types out
there be grateful for the how types even
if they may frustrate you sometimes and
you how types even though the Y types
may trust you sometimes you guys make
amazing teams and those make the best
teams I also talked about run Bruder I
thought I would share a story where I
learned something else that's not in the
book so Ron I met Ron
and I got to write about him and he
became a very very close friend and he
also became one of my mentors he's a
remarkable human being and it was from
Ron that I actually learned more about
what mentorship really means you know I
get emails from people that say you know
will you be my mentor and the answer's
no I won't for the same reason that if
you sent me an email it just said will
you be my friend yeah I look like I
don't even know you
like we can't do that you can't go up to
it we can't go up to strangers and say
will you be my friend it's a little
weird right and this is what I started
to learn about mentorship it's exactly
the same as friendship friendship I
didn't ask
Rawdon to be my mentor like a friend it
evolved and and what I learned as a
mentor is someone who always has time
for you after I met run I remember I
wanted his advice on something and I
called him up and this is before start
with white took off before there was a
TED talk and there was no start with why
because I was still interviewing Ron and
I remember calling him up and I wanted
his advice and he took my call he's a
very successful guy he took my call and
he gave me earnest advice and I remember
some weeks later I called him again and
he took my call again he kept making
time for me and eventually what happened
is a friendship evolved and I remember I
was at his house once this is well into
our friendship and I was getting ready
to leave and I put my arm around him as
I was getting ready to say goodbye and I
said you know Ron I love that you're my
mentor and he looked back and said
something to me that I didn't expect he
said and I love that you're mine now
this is when I realized that mentor
relationships aren't mentor mentee it's
not like that's not just teacher-student
but it's rather mentor mentor that
sometimes I didn't realize that though I
was coming to him for advice that he was
learning from me - just like friendship
sometimes we're the givers in our friend
in our friendships sometimes we're the
receivers in our friendships it's it's
it's this beautiful it's this beautiful
thing so mentor relationships are not
like champions you know you have someone
at your company who's your champion you
expect them to like put your name
forward for a promotion mentors don't
get involved in your in your career
they're just there and they believe in
you so thanks to Ron brooder I learned a
lot more about what mentorship means and
it's really much more like
in friendship the celery test one of my
favorite little metaphors probably more
poignant in these times than ever which
is even with the new stresses even with
the fact that we are reinventing our
organization's reinventing ourselves
reinventing our jobs reinventing so much
even figuring out what our definition of
success and life looks like you know how
we're defining success less about
productivity and and more about taking
time for family taking time for
ourselves this is we're learning these
lessons the celery test means staying
true to your why and though the Watts
will change and though we can adapt how
we do things regardless of the times
regardless of the situation regardless
of where we work the y must still remain
clear so I thought that was that was it
really it struck me again I hadn't
thought about the celery test my well
and I realized even now as I'm learning
new things and I'm doing different
things I've never done a book club
before this is because of corona that
we're doing this I realized that I still
have to stay true to why I do what I do
it's still the celery and I can change
what I do so those are some of the
things that reminded that really stood
out for me as I read this chapter it's a
this section I really love that this
section is about the building of
movement and how it requires a lot of us
coming together and these and the idea
that none of us can do these things by
ourselves no matter how strong or how
clear our Y is it really is about
partnership so with that why don't we
take some questions we have some pre
submitted questions plus we will take as
many live questions as we can so please
go ahead and write them in and I'll get
them over here here's one I now read
from Lexie hi Lexi gravina since the
founders personality and the company's
personality are aligned does the
personality or the Y of the company get
altered when the founder is no longer
part of the company such a good question
if things are done right the answer is
no if the founder leaves the company and
the Y has been properly engrained into
the company
if the founder leaves the company should
still be able to embody the founding
purpose cause our belief from when the
founder was there
unfortunately what so often happens is
we tend to promote the wrong people into
the into those positions we tend to
promote I hate to say it we tend to
promote the how people into a why job we
tend to promote the operators and the
people that know how to build and so
instead of looking up and out to use
Laurie Laura Robinson's language they
look down and in they become more
focused on the short term and the why
starts to go fuzzy we've seen this
repeat over and over again I've written
about this you know Microsoft was a big
why focused company Steve Ballmer came
in it became much more much more what
focused and we see this happen over and
over unfortunately but a great example
is take a nation-state take the United
States for example the Y was established
in the Declaration of Independence it's
gone in and out of fuzziness depending
on the the history but the Y has been
able to survive beyond the founding
fathers it's the same for company and
you'll very often hear that companies
will go through hard times or bad
leadership and they'll come out of it
and the new leadership will say we have
to go back to basics well that doesn't
mean we're gonna make the products that
we made you know 20 30 years ago it
means what we have to go back to our
founding values and our founding why
good question
Lexie alright let's take another
question here's one from the sorry about
the paper rustles there here's one from
the pearls of wisdom book club hello
folks at Chanel we love you you talk
about the alignment of why with regards
to corporate cultures how do you foresee
the pandemic impacting corporate
cultures going forward well hopefully
this is exaggerated all of the good
stuff in corporate culture remember the
best of corporate culture is when it's
people focused the why when when founded
by a visionary founder like Coco Chanel
in your case is always focused on people
it's always focused on a visionary
version of the world it's not
necessarily just about us so what I'm
hoping the pandemic does it's it's
forced us all to really reconnect with
the people side of our businesses and we
realize how valuable the people are
even when our products and our
marketplace has been shaken so what I'm
really hoping when we come out of this
is that there will be more focus on
corporate culture and more focus on
things like empathy a skill that we've
been practicing during the pandemic so
I'm actually optimistic that when things
return to whatever new abnormal is going
to be that we actually see much more
focus much more earnest and sincere
focus on corporate culture not just not
just lip service
Ignacio yes how can you start with why
when you're a person okay
remember everybody has a why and your
and you will always start with why
whether you're a Y person or a how
person right the Y is the motivation the
Y personality they're wise tend to be
things like you'll like mine is about
inspiring you know it's very lofty and
in the clouds and you know you've tend
to find the how types they're wise a
much more functional things like
building constructing you know serving
helping supporting you'll see though
that language in a how and a how types
why statement and by the way they love
that you know when they hear that
they're there to build or support like
that that is warms their heart so
everybody starts with why it's it's it's
the function of the why is that right to
say yeah but you still start with why
you still start with your why even if
you're a how type it's it's it's the
role your your your your why takes and
it helps you identify the best kind of
partners because we have complimentary
wise we don't have exact wise we have
wise that work together good question
there here is one from Lydia she's a
member of the Y is here book club I
thought why was here just saying how do
you know if you were why or a how type
of person are there are other types
beyond why and how that are needed to
ensure people live to their wise I guess
I think I've probably already addressed
that one you'll know because of where
you find you know if you're a white I
poor how type because you'll know what's
easy for you
I have a friend she is a very very
successful entrepreneur she's very very
how oriented she's and she and I would
go for lunch together and literally we
would get so mad at each other they were
the most frustrating lunches but could
she would give me a business advice like
why did you just do this and why did you
just do that why'd you do this like it
was easy and I took it as an I took it
like I got so offended because she
touched a nerve because she was telling
me to do things that are so easy for her
that are so difficult for me like why
don't you just build the structure and
figure out a system and do that and then
just implement it like ah and then and
she would ask me for business advice and
I would talk about you know these lofty
visionary things that what why did you
just do this it's so easy and she would
go so mad at me because those things
were so hard for her and they were the
funniest lunches we get so mad at each
other because we were touching nerves is
what was happening so where is your
natural where's your natural cadence
what do you actually find easy like my
friend - Jamison she's so good at
implementing vision but she can't
necessarily come up with it she can't
necessarily come up with a big idea but
if you give her one she'll make it
happen no no problem that's how you can
tell and you'll definitely frustrating
all the time
here's the lime-green and tangerine book
club I like that
is it tangerine the fruit or tan during
the color because you said was
lime-green is a tangerine orange or is
it the fruit anyway lime green and
tangerine book-club we are teachers at
the high school level and we are
wondering how the golden circle relates
to public education we seen many
connections and want to improve the
culture and climate of our school great
question so remember a company is a
company it's a group of people it's the
fact that it's a business is just a
legal structure but it's the group of
people who come together in common cause
a hospital a school it's all the same
thing it's a group of people who come
together in common cause and the why of
the school is extremely important to
understand because not all schools have
the same cultures as a teacher you know
that you've worked in different schools
and depending on what the leadership is
you'll have a very different culture
universe
the same just because there's two highly
rated schools that you want to send your
kids to for example the reason we go
visit them and the reason we go on tours
and the reason we do our research
because we we will also want understand
the culture of the school because we
want our kids to be good fits in the
culture so they will map more naturally
thrive in that culture and that's really
really important so a school is the same
the school has a culture and we want to
articulate the wive of the school so
what ideally we want to do is if there
is a if there is an origin story of the
school you want to go back to that
origin story if there isn't if you have
good leadership then we want to know the
why of the principle of the
administration the administrator or
there's another way to do it you can
find out what the there's a if you go
through the why discovery process you
can get to the why with a group as well
different conversation but yes we want
to articulate the why and just like a
company we want to write it on the walls
we wanted at the beginning of
announcements we want to give awards to
both teachers and and people who work in
the school and and students for people
who are upholding advancing the wine
upholding the values you treat it like
any other it's got marketing it's got a
incentive structures you want to hire
teachers who who believe in the why you
say this is what we stand for do you
think you'd like to be here and then you
have all the different personality types
all the different diversity all of the
all of the people who come to a school
and make it wonderful and fantastic and
bring that cause to life it works
exactly the same way you can replace the
word company with school in the book
start with why and it will read
perfectly fine
lauren representing the compass within
book club
what is your creative process for
discovering ways to bring your y to life
so it's it's a lot of spaghetti thrown
against a wall some of it sticks so
remember y is a filter and when we apply
that filter we it's much easier to see
things when we see that filter so for
example if i say go out on the street
and find all the people that you could
be friends with well you actually know
how to do that you know how to make
friends we all know how to make friends
it's time-consuming and it's a little
bit like well I have to try meet lots of
people and some of those people I'll
connect with in some of those I won't
but what if we apply a filter what if we
say go outside on the street and find
all the people wearing blue shirts easy
there's one there's one there's one
there's one you can instantly find them
so when you know your why it acts like a
filter it actually believe it or not
becomes much much easier to see
opportunities and actually to see what
are the right decisions and the wrong
decisions with great leap becomes almost
automatic when you know your why so I'll
give you a personal example I the things
that I say yes to the things that I say
no to so I'm about inspiring people to
do things that inspire them
so together each of us can change our
world for the better and my vision might
just cause is to create a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single morning inspired feel safe
wherever they are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do so
when I get an offer to do a speaking
engagement I my favorite ones to take
are when it's an industry organization
with five thousand people attending
representing three thousand different
companies because my message is a
mass-market message that I'm attempting
to move the needle and push versus a
company that calls me and says we'd like
you to come talk to our top 30 sales
reps they may offer me more money but
I'll turn it down because it doesn't
it's not that's not helping me advance
my cause talking to thirty people from a
one organization I'm not gonna move the
needle and I only have limited time on
this planet I have to make certain bets
and the bets I want to make are ones
that advance the cause more so when you
know you're white it worked like this
beautiful filter also I rely on others I
bring it up with other people and we
don't talk about is this good for the
business we talk about is this good for
the movement and by by saying is this
the right decision for the movement what
I'm asking my team to do is everyone
please filter the this through our
filter and see if it holds up good
question
hi Simon 18 what do you think is the
first step in repairing trust if
possible and it's been lost between why
and help people ah so good so the
question was what is the first step to
take Thank You Dylan for your question
what is the first step to take to repair
a trust if it's been lost between the
how and the why people in other words if
we got so frustrated each other we just
brushed each other off and said you
don't get it that's what we said about
each other you don't understand you need
the details and I'll say you'd
understand where we're going and we get
mad at each other well remember be the
leader you wish you had one of you has
to take the risk to be vulnerable one of
you has to call up and say I'm sorry the
RIC and then and and the reason that I
got mad has less to do with you and more
to do with me because you're so good at
the things that I'm bad at that when you
talk to me as if because it's so easy
for you it makes me feel stupid and then
this is by the way this is the
conversation I had with my friend that
when you say those things the reason I
react react so angrily is because I feel
dumb because it's so easy for you and I
struggle to understand it that I get
emotional and I'm sorry and very often
they'll say something very similar
because they'll find the similar insight
so the repairing of the trust and so and
so there's little techniques that you
can learn to help each other so for
example I'll give you two very very
simple ones as awhile why type I'm
always thinking out loud and I'm four
I'm always in an iterative process you
can hear it while I'm answering
questions right watching me to think out
loud now if there's a how type sitting
next to me how types usually think
before they speak I just speak right you
I'm speaking my thoughts and so this can
be very difficult for how types because
every word that's coming out of my mouth
they think that that's what I want them
to do and so they're making these big
long lists of things to do and then
they'll bring something to me and say
look what I did I'm like I didn't tell
you to do that they're like yes you did
you said it I'm like I never said it and
they'll show me look you said it well I
didn't mean it I'll say well then they
like well how do I know if you said
something so what I've learned to do
when I start speaking I say I'm just
thinking out loud here
and all the how types could put their
pens down and allow me to go through my
process and then when I come to a
conclusion I can say something like I
think this is what I want us to do right
so I say I'm thinking out loud that
allows people to know that's what's
happening for the how types was
immensely valuable is at the end of a
meeting at the end of a conversation the
end of a discussion they say let me just
summarize what I what we're doing next
and they'll go through their summary and
it gives me the opportunity to say oh no
no no not that one not that one but yes
to that one so I now I prepare them they
summarize great little technique if you
can get into that habit you'll both help
each other out a huge huge amount okay
let's take another live question should
we somebody wrote about Anna Maria about
logo and name for a company should it
reflect the why intangible emotional or
the what make it easy to relate your
name to the computer you're up to the
product you're offering so the question
is is should the name and logo be
representative of your cause or should
it be representative of your product
okay there's a danger in naming your
company after your product is what
happens if you want to make different
products so for example there's this
there's a there's a store in the United
Kingdom called Carphone Warehouse it's
really weird that it's called carphone
warehouse now because it's basically an
electronic store and it seems outdated
because it came from a time when they
just sold you guessed it car phones
those big things that used to get
installed in our cars with telephone
wire you remember those so it's makes it
seem outdated it makes it seem behind
the times
even Apple Apple Apple's legal name used
to be Apple Computer and they changed it
to just Apple because they recognized
that they were doing more than just
their product
now does that does it need to be named
after the Y you can infuse words with
meaning but you're more likely to able
to infuse a word with meaning that has
no specific
meaning unto itself it's not based on
any product this is why so often look
how many companies and named after names
Dell Boeing Walmart I mean they're all
Disney those are all human they're all
people they're all people's names and
they become infused with meaning over
over over the years so I I generally
recommend naming a company based on
nothing based on a made-up word or based
on the philosophy or where you're going
or something that based on your why and
not on and and same with a logo you
really don't want to have a mark that is
just a picture of a of whatever it is
you're doing because what if you're not
doing that anymore something more
abstract is a little more flexible and
long-term oriented Oh a lot of people
asking what because you can see team
mine says team optimist I thought that
was a good t-shirt to wear today because
that's us we are team optimists on this
book club focus for it's being positive
helping each other out
yeah book club Jen growl Jen growl asks
should you give trust freely from the
beginning of joining an organization or
is it something that is earned by the
organization over time Oh such a hard
question
so the funny thing is is we often get
this wrong leaders often get this wrong
it's the leaders who have to bestow
trust immediately not the other way
around you know very often we went to
our company and leaders will say to new
people you know or to any employee for
that matter you have to prove to me that
I should trust you actually it goes the
other way it comes from us the the
rank-and-file who say to our leaders
will prove to us why we should trust you
because remember they have the authority
we don't there are the alphas we're not
and so they're supposed to be the
protectors so we're not going to make
ourselves vulnerable until we can be
sure that our alphas will protect us
they have to earn our trust not the
other way around this is why leaders
have to lead by example we won't be
honest about our failings our mistakes
and our fallible
until we see that our leaders do that
and offer us a safe space for us to do
the same because if we just come out and
start trusting and start saying all the
things I got wrong and all the mistakes
I made and we're in an organization that
that would actually hurt us and get us
fired or get us or we won't get a
promotion because of it then guess what
we're not saying a word or we'll get
fired so it's actually ironic yes you
you want to come in not totally cynical
obviously it's like a friendship you
don't show up on the first day of
friendship and be like well let me tell
you it's it's a dance but the irony is
it is the responsibility of leadership
to take the risk to trust first and then
we will respond in kind it goes in that
order Thank You general good question
why believers book club yeah yeah so the
question was there are Y people there
how people are there what people there
are no web people what people what is
the tangible product the tangible work
the countable measurable something or
other that is produced by the Y or the
help person and best or the combination
of those why and how people so whatever
they make do say is is the what
so no there's just I don't know I don't
even have a metaphor and analogy because
they just don't exist remember it's
about a perspective why folks tend to be
more focused on the on the on the forest
for the trees and how people are in the
woods going okay I see that you want to
go in that direction the problem there's
a big boulder in the way so I'm gonna
turn this way and we're gonna go around
the boulder so that we can get to the
direction you're pointing because the
white person lives above the trees how
persons in the trees and they have to
trust each other because if the white
person looks down and says why are you
going sideways I told you to go that way
they have to trust that they're
navigating around the trees and through
the rocks that it's not a straight line
it's like a submarine captain says go
due north submarine does not travel in a
straight line it travels like this but
the captain doesn't have to say no a
little to the left no a little to the
right
the crew knows to go in that basic
direction same thing why person sets the
course how person figures out the path
through all the obstacles that is the
best so that's why they have to trust
each other because one will be screaming
I told you this direction they don't say
can't you see I we have to go in this
direction and unless they're talking and
communicating you're gonna have issues
Devon Kay from India asked what is the
difference between Y and purpose so when
I wrote start with y there were these
constant debates I kept having with
people like what comes first vision or
mission and who cares right and the
problem was we were having semantic
debates and so I went to people who
believed vision comes first I said well
what's vision and they said well it's
why we get out of bed in the morning and
I went to people and said well what's
mission people who believe mission Kames
first and they said well it's why our
company exists and I went to the people
who believed bran comes first or purpose
comes first or DNA comes for whatever
whatever words they used and they all
gave me the same definition it's why we
do what we do so I decided to call it
the why so we could all agree because I
got tired having a tired of having these
semantic debates and then we'd make no
progress because we're trying to
convince people of our definition of
words so I called it the Y so what is
the the difference between Y and purpose
well I know what Y is because I we've
defined it together but purpose has so
many different meanings I mean even if
you go to a company's website and they
say you know you can tell we're purpose
driven because look we give so much
money to charity that's not purpose
that's just charity so I tend to avoid
those words and if you see in the
definition of why I call it purpose
cause or belief I put them all in there
so yeah I tend to not use the word
purpose unless I'm crystal clear that we
all agree that it's the same definition
ok let's take a look at some other live
questions look how many people here it's
wonderful so nice to see everybody could
you be both a why and how type no.1 is
purely one or the other of course of
course of like if I were purely why I'd
never get anything done but of course
I'm somewhat functional but for me to
work in an extreme how environment like
writing a book it's way more stressful
for me it's much harder work for me so
that you know that if stress goes up
it's because you're in a position of
discomfort or weakness but yeah of
course of course
nobody's perfect it's a Venn diagram
it's not completely separated well you
know how people can still understand
vision and have vision but we're not not
everybody's you know Elon Musk or
Richard Branson mean those are some
serious visionaries in Richard Branson's
first to admit he didn't know how to
read a balance sheet when he's been it
started his company he surrounded
himself with a brilliant people first to
admit and you tend to find that that the
best in both is that they have the
ability to and this was the thing that -
learned as well the best of both are
able to admit what they're good at and
what they're not good at and why they
need each other that humility is really
important big love Club in Cambridge hi
Cambridge is a lovely town so my boss is
a how type and I'm a why type what do I
do
well you you have to be a remember it's
not a hierarchy it's just that we tend
to have the visionary person stand on
the steps to give the speeches because
they're they're good at it let's be
honest they're inspiring but it is a
partnership and so the the you can help
your boss find the words that your boss
may be struggling to communicate clearly
I find this very often with some really
well-intentioned leaders who are how
types but they're really good people who
are trying to do the right thing and
they have some semblance of vision that
they've cobbled together but they
struggle to get it out clearly and so
this is where great speech writing you
know helps not all leaders write their
own words but rather it's those Y types
that may help them write the words I'll
do that for people behind the scenes
there's a bunch of folks that I that I
work with who are fantastic how types
they're good people
they're they want to build up good
organizations and I help them find the
words that they're trying to put out
there that will inspire people so help
your boss
leverage everything that you have you
have to offer
Simon is why really about underlying
motivations asked Roland de Silva yes it
is this is you know we can be motivated
by things externally you know I'll give
you a bonus if that's motivation if you
don't do your homework you get no
dessert I can be motivated to do my
homework too a threat of punishment but
inspiration is something much deeper
yes it's an internal drive it's based on
our values it's based on our our desire
for legacy it's based on our of the
world we want to leave behind is based
on service it's it's it's it's something
has to be burning bright and side as if
we're willing to sacrifice we're
willingly sacrifice something to be a
part of something so I tend to find that
motivation is important but it tends to
be much shorter lived it's harder to be
motivated every moment of every day
sometimes we have bad days sometimes we
don't get enough sleep and I'm not
motivated or I or something happened and
I'm really not motivated but inspiration
can can still live on you know I very
often equivalent equivalent what's the
word make it equivalent to we'll just
skip the grammar make it equivalent to
like loving your children versus liking
your children you know you don't have to
like your kids every day but you love
them every day it's the same thing you
can you can be inspired even if you're
not motivated but internal-external is a
good a good differentiate or okay let's
see what else we have how do we help
people find their why from the
professional resource center book club
Thank You Corey okay so this happened
last week was we would we were about
finding your why okay so we told you
last week that we launched our jumpstart
your why workshop and we did it as a
little beta and we only told book club
about it and you guys were so wonderful
and so fantastic and so eager that you
all went to get a seat in that in that
workshop at the exact same time that it
crashed
our website because it got too much
traffic so here's the good news we will
be offering more jumpstart your why
workshops please don't rush over to the
website right now they have been posted
there's a new shop tab there are new
jumpstart your why workshops you can go
there it's pay what you can so whatever
you can afford that's the price it's pay
what you can please maybe take a couple
days to go have a look and if it sells
out don't worry we're gonna add more
because it worked the first time thank
you for those early adopters who tried
it we're gonna do it we also added a
bunch of other classes what we've been
doing over the past two or three weeks
going through our own existential flex
reinventing and what we've tried to do
is produce a whole bunch of live
workshops in other words they're not
recorded there they're live and
interactive too a lot of themes that are
really important to people right now
things like how to pivot with purpose
pivot under pressure - how do we
reinvent reinvent ourselves in this
marketplace we have a class for that we
have a class on how to have difficult
conversations that's a big one right now
- so please go to simon Sinek comm
slowly not all at once maybe a few now
maybe a few later maybe a few this
afternoon maybe a few this evening maybe
a few this weekend we've got a bunch of
classes and if they sell out don't worry
we're gonna add more but we have some
availability for classes even as early
as next week so please go check it out
we can help you find your why as well as
a bunch of other really cool stuff thank
you for that question what else do we
have
[Music]
great question kind of how person
transition to a why person and can a
white person transition to a how person
mmm not really
you're really playing to your natural
strengths now a why person can get
better at practicing and learning and
understanding structure and how to build
it and how person can get better at
learning to appreciate and understand
the value of of things that are
intangible sometimes and and and and and
big broad things but it's what really if
we could just learn the other skill and
be as competent in it
then we wouldn't need each other then to
be literally no point of four teams the
reality is their natural dispositions
their personality they seem to be more
like personality types yes you can
always mitigate and again I stress no
one's purely one or the other we're all
combinations some more or less so yes
I'm better at structure than I used to
be like reading start with why like I'm
looking forward to updating it because I
wouldn't there's a lot of sort of like
little things in there that are driving
me nuts that I wouldn't that I didn't do
in the later books because I learned how
to write a book better because I
realized it's a highly structured
environment I got better at it also I
don't do it alone when I write my books
I have somebody who's an extremely good
how type help me organize my thoughts
remember I work with someone that's what
produces the better work so that's how
it is okay what else do we have out here
so is some Sultan has been asking many
times to get it it's like the equivalent
of the kid in school it's cool good Oh
me me me me me so yes some essential
tennis how can I work inspiring Lea ie
in a vision of why into a company which
has a vision of what if if I can apply
the vision of why in the company on a
level of my department thank you so I
get this question so often is um thank
you for bringing it up again I think
it's so important and sadly really
really really common I'm in middle
management I work for a company I'm why
driven I believe in all this stuff but
what do I do if the company is just
numbers driven I've all they do is care
about process and they don't care about
vision or having an impact well we
cannot control that which we cannot
control we certainly can't change people
and no number of anonymously sent books
will ever change how they are the best
thing we can do is be the leaders we
wish we had that's the best thing we can
do so you can lead with Y in your team
and remember there's no it's not like
you'll tend to find that the that the Y
types tend to gravitate to things like
marketing or things like product
development and then how types tend to
gravitate towards things like finance
not purely not purely not purely but you
tend to see patterns you know operations
because that's their natural strengths
now you very often find Y types and
finance but these are the big idea
finance people the big idea operations
people and inspire the other people in
operations and so what you want to do is
is lead to your natural type you even if
you're a how type you can still you can
still be very inspiring to be around
when you start with your Y your Y
inspires people regardless of your
natural disposition so Sultan
I mean Islam you know the the answer
which is be the leader you wish you had
take care of your team lead with Y with
your team and we'll see what happens
yes les DeMint a book club Sasha
[Music]
we're gonna have to do everything on my
own so the question was such a good one
what do you do if you're a freelancer
and you don't have that partnership
where you where you you have to be both
well the answer is you're gonna be
working in times of strength and
weakness more often than others I've
been there I know exactly what it's like
as a white person trying to build a
business by myself it was excruciating
ly difficult and I ended up relying on
force of personality because I didn't
know how to build structure how tight
will probably be more successful in
building businesses quite frankly
because they can get the structure right
and get the process right but they may
not operate at a scale that is is can
change the world and if they quit or
retire or die
the odds are much higher that the
company will just close because there
was nothing there was there's no
inspirational vision that was holding
the people together that they would want
to continue to build the company without
their leader this is very very common
most entrepreneurial ventures in the
United States unless they're passed on
to family which is different because
family you're upholding your legacy so
there's there's that tend to go away in
other words we have about 27 million I
think that's the number if memory serves
27 million small businesses in the
United States it's not 27 now 30 40 50
be growing if those companies survive
but they don't so if you're a freelancer
I mean it's hard now you can still ask
for help you know if you have friends
who are particularly good at division
stuff ask them to help you articulate or
write your your marketing emails or how
you should start meetings or what's the
first page of your PowerPoint when you
give a presentation ask help ask for
help I do that for a lot of folks I
really help with the front pages of
things help with the cover or the first
page of how to open a meeting and then I
let them go do all their structure stuff
because they're so good at it but I help
figure out how to start but with why
otherwise I get straight into the
details like they started meeting like
okay guys so on Thursday we did I'm like
well let's let's back it up but if
you're the how tight if you're the why
type go ask for help from somebody who's
really good
structure you know if you're if you're
bootstrapping it then you friends will
help us can you help me build a process
how do i do invoicing you know what's
the right thing to do what's the
structure to do and and we help each
other it's still a team even if that
person isn't working with you formally
or being paid for their work teams come
in all shapes and sizes so we're talking
a lot about how types of why types but
it's I won't also want to talk about
some of the other things like discipline
I mean remember the ciliary the salary
test was about discipline and the
concept of the cone I just love this
idea that the Golden Circle is actually
not two-dimensional but
three-dimensional that it is actually
basically a metaphor for how a company
looks and operates that companies or
whatever it is even our jobs are really
megaphones and that at the core of that
megaphone that you know you just have
the image of the megaphone like a
message has to go in to the megaphone
right that's the wife that comes from us
we're the representative the why the
mechanism is well how I'm going to make
it from soft to loud well that's the
actual megaphone and what comes out of
it the words that come out of it that's
the what right so a company what goes
into it is the inspiration the vision
the cause right it's all in there the
company itself it's making stuff its
producing stuff and what comes out the
other end is a product to consume words
to hear that's a product to consume we
consume Martin Luther King's words that
was his product and I just absolutely
love that as a metaphor and it really
helps understand the hierarchy of an
organization that when you're in front
if you're in the if you're on the front
line you're really you know what job I'm
I'm I'm right they're making producing
serving you know making the French fries
at in-and-out burger this french fries
ever best burgers every - that's right
right there in the front and then as you
go up you know middle management is
really this this this we have to manage
between between the both between the
inspiration coming from up on high and
getting the actual job down that's how
we gonna do this how am I gonna turn
that into that that's really what middle
management is I just love that metaphor
because it's so true and the most fun
thing is that if the golden circle is
based on biology
which it is that means there's a
biological construction to a business
that there's a limbic component that
should be at the top of the organization
and a new your cortical component that's
that's down that's down below so we have
too much neocortex at the top too much
everything's done with numbers alone and
calculations it loses the inspiration
but we have to weigh them if we there's
not enough of that at the frontline then
we never produce anything it's all just
hippie communes stuff and we never
actually make anything that's what
happens when you have too much wire in
the front lines are not enough not
enough get things done so it's it's a
it's a nice magical little combination
there yes great idea well so the the the
suggestion was at the end of this
revised 10-year anniversary edition of
start with why that I can include some
of the common questions I get about
start with why with the answers at the
back of the book that's a great idea I
think I might actually do that things
like what do you do if you're a high
person and what do you do if you're a
white person the middle of the
organization that was include that one
in the back that's a great idea thank
you I think I will do that okay this is
a great one from Paul Moran should a
dominant how persons start a business
adopt entrepreneurial role or employ a
wide person to do this role it doesn't
matter who starts the business anybody
can start a business
Rollins Inge who's a how type he was the
one who actually started Southwest
Airlines but he brought in her abdellah
her who was his divorce attorney who was
a better who's better at leading with
why if Rollins said well I'm the founder
of the company as my business is my idea
you play the second fiddle you don't you
know I want to keep you in the shadows
Southwest would not be what it is today
it would just be just another functional
airline so it was actually Rowling King
who had the insight
that that the airline business was
really for only 15% of the traveling
population it was really only for the
elites and he said well what about
everybody else and he was the one who
said we don't compete against the car we
don't compete against other airlines we
compete against the car in the bus but
it was it was he had the insight but
Kelleher knew how to how to preach and
how to and how to lead the people and I
see this very very often I see I can't
tell you how come it I see this both in
entrepreneurial ventures and even in
some very successful businesses where
the inspirational founder because
there's such a y type they don't trust
themselves and so they asked their
friend who's much better at business to
be the CEO and I won't mention some of
the companies but there's some companies
that you know that are like that and and
though those leaders may be good
executives and good people and believe
in the cause the problem is we need them
to preach need them to share the Y and
they're not there write down and in in
the weeds in in the functioning of the
company and even the company will do
well it won't survive it won't inspire
it won't it won't change industries
meaning it won't profoundly shift the
the way an industry works it's really
that magical partnership there's a
couple of friends that I have now who
where because one of them is better at
business more structured they made her
the the CEO and I and I realized that
and I said no no you got you would have
the positions backwards you have the
positions backwards she should be the
CEO because she'll be leveraging her
strengths much more and it's really it's
about ego because the titles don't mean
anything you know we have this false
belief that CEO goes first and and CEO
or CFO goes second it's complete rubbish
it's a partnership it's CEO and CIO it's
not one and two it's one in a there
they're equal
they're equals in rank of different
capabilities that work in partnership
and the egos have to be in check for
that so ya know and it doesn't matter
what personality type you are if you
start the business
but it-it-it will help you determine
what role you should play as the
business continues to grow in the early
days it was Steve Wozniak if somebody
asked about Apple if Steve Jobs was the
Y person his Tim Cook the how person so
in the early days it was Steve Wozniak
was was the engineer and even though was
shared all the same vision as Jobs was
imagined a world in which one day an
individual could compete against an evil
corporation by themselves because of the
power of the personal computer but God
bless was he's an amazing visionary
person but sometimes he speaks it's like
an engineer you know it's it takes a
long time to get what to understand what
he's trying to get it I thought that was
ironic because it took me a long time to
get that out Jobs was much more succinct
and visionary in his language but yes
Tim Cook is a how type he was the CEO of
Apple for many many many years so that's
a whole different discussion where now
you have a hype running visionary
company what happens so I realized some
of what I wrote about Apple mmm
interesting so that's a conversation for
another time I think we've come to the
end of another wonderful inspiring
fantastic amazing book club thank you
everyone for joining we will be back
here where my notes here they are we
will be back again next Friday
same bat-time same bat-channel at 3:00
p.m. Eastern part five the biggest
challenge our penultimate episode the
biggest challenge is success will be May
1st
please get together with your book clubs
read ahead submit your questions to book
club at simon Sinek calm remember the
whole point of book club is not about
reading the book it's about doing
something with each other
that's the important part if you want to
watch or re-watch or go back and hear
another answer that was given
or we are posting these on YouTube feel
free to go back and use them for
reference whenever you like if you have
a friend or someone in your book club
missed the live session they will be up
and share it on all our social media
platforms um thank you to everyone again
who took the jump start your why beta
last week it was very very successful
and we're very happy it did you guys are
amazing
so jumpstart your why is sold-out thank
you we will add more we're gonna add
more as long as you guys are interested
in it we'll just keep adding more
classes we're actually training up some
more people so we can we can do more of
them more and remember there's other
classes up there as well starting next
week that we hope you enjoy as well
thank you for coming thank you for
joining again this is about doing
something with each other take care of
yourselves take care of each other I'll
see you next week